Let's talk about why we're washing our
hands, right? How many of you
have tried to cook? And if you cook, like say you make a grilled cheese
and I like to make my grilled cheese with
like a lot of butter in the pan, and so
it ends up my pan after I eat my grilled
cheese my pan is full of like butter and
grease, right? Does anybody
feel-- seen-- that before? Like a pan is
like really greasy from like cooking
food? Well, if I were to take that pan and
run it under water would it clean the
pan? Just plain water. What do you think?
No, right? You can't just take a bunch of
grease on a pan and put it under water
and expect it to be clean. You have to
add something. What do you have to add?
Yeah, go ahead. Some sort of soap or some natural, like, cleanser. Yeah, a cleaning product
like a soap, right? And, that's because the molecules inside of butter
like it's a special
kind of fat, right? They're actually the
same type of molecules that surround the
Coronavirus, and so if we see that our
soap is dissolving all of the fat inside
of our pan and making our pans clean,
then it makes a lot of sense that soap
can also dissolve the fat that surrounds
the Coronavirus to get the Coronavirus
sort of like off of your -- off of your
hands. So, that's a really good-- we always
need to wash our hands. I know I have to
use lotion now because my hands are so
dry because I'm always washing my hands,
and so that's really really important